solidarity for women's rights around the
world was one of the main themes of a
March in Paris to Mark International
women's day that protesters also focus
on issues closer to home including the
French government's planned pension
reform that some say will make life
harder for women
like all reforms this pension Bill
ignores women now women will have to
work more years to make up for the years
they had children as if having children
is at work to status against women as
all states are and unless governments
include women you end up with laws like
this pension reform which is profoundly
sexist this small
with the second day of Nationwide
strikes against the government's plan
pension reforms
some workers say the reforms are an
erosion of their rights in the north of
the country there were Road blockades
and picket lines outside some factories
in the East dozens of cargo boat workers
blocked part of the Rhine River while
Transport Services were disrupted
Nationwide
it's been total chaos I guess it's the
same for everyone I had a train this
afternoon that was canceled so I
rebooked and then that was Kim
trade unions are calling for Rolling
strikes to bring France to a standstill
angering the government
we condemn calls to bring our economy to
its knees because these statements are
irresponsible union leaders also want to
meet French president Emmanuel macron to
discuss the standoff so far the requests
have been declined Macross says the
reforms are necessary to modernize an
ailing and costly system and for now his
government shows no sign of backing down
Natasha Butler Al Jazeera Paris